well thank you so much to the organizers
of this conference for inviting me to to
participate
my name is Laurence Ann Curry I am the
Associate Director of the neuro ethics
program at the Cleveland Clinic and just
finished up a fellowship funded by the
NIH brain initiative focused on ethical
challenges in early phase brain device
research and particularly some of the
ethical challenges that arise at the end
of clinical trials of implanted devices
such as deep brain stimulation and so
I'm excited to present some of the
findings from my research that was
funded by the brain initiative to you
today and my objectives with with this
presentation are to describe for some of
those ethical challenges that arise in
early early phase brain device research
as well as some of the the practical and
ethical issues that arise when
attempting to obtain initial and ongoing
consent in these early phase clinical
trials and then to reflect on the rule
of ethics to help support brain device
research and make sure that we're
upholding the best possible practices in
this area of clinical research
so to give an overview first of just
where ethical challenges might arrive in
early phase clinical research there
there are certainly challenges that come
up before you get to the point of
conducting a first inhuman study and
those are outside of the scope of my
presentation today but I will will
discuss some of the implications of the
ethical issues I've explored
at the end of this presentation the
first area that the ethical challenges
might arise once you're involving human
subjects in clinical research involving
brain devices is during recruitment and
so we'll discuss some of the challenges
that might arise just in identifying the
right patient population to enroll in
clinical studies and and then we'll move
on to that initial consent process once
you've identified a good candidate to
first
brain device research obtaining consent
as they initially enroll in a clinical
trial can be complicated by some some
important ethical issues and then once a
research participant has decided to
enroll in a clinical trial their ethical
challenge of challenges that arise
related to ongoing consent and making
sure that the participants continue to
to be involved in research in a
voluntary and informed way then we'll
explore exit from clinical research
which was the focus of my empirical
neuro ethics research and it's an area
that I've I've done quite a bit of
research in terms of what regulations
apply at the end of a clinical trial
once participants are about to exit from
a clinical trial and then finally we'll
discuss some complex challenges that
come up related to post trial access to
brain devices and important decisions
that are made about whether to provide
access to research participants to these
devices once they're no longer in
enrolled in a clinical protocol a
clinical trial protocol so to start with
challenges during recruitment of
research participants to important
ethical issues to pay attention to you
are first the vulnerability of potential
research subjects and so eligibility to
participate in a brain device trial is
often limited to two individuals who
have treatment refractory and chronic
disorders brain devices generally are
not explored as first-line therapeutic
modalities and so usually in order for
for an individual to be eligible to
participate in this kind of research
they've they've been they've experienced
a great deal of time with a neurological
disorder and they have probably tried
numerous medical therapies and other
treatment modalities before considering
enrollment in a clinical trial and so
this raises concerns about about
potential vulnerability about a sense of
desperation that individuals might have
if they don't feel like there are other
other that there are treatment options
or maybe other research trials that they
consider enrolling in so there it's
important to be attentive to how to
safeguard against concerns about undue
and do influence or coercion in just
identifying who might be a good
candidate to recruit for a clinical
trial of an investigational brain device
and the second concern is is
establishing appropriate inclusion
exclusion criteria I mean more
importantly as you're attempting to
recruit participants avoiding bias when
attempting to make sure that potential
participants have motivations that are
consistent with being a part of clinical
research and anticipating whether you've
identified an individual who's likely to
adhere to a treatment protocol once
you're actually at the point of
obtaining initial consent to be a part
of clinical research and this consent
process can be complicated first by
therapeutic misconception or a
misunderstanding of just the fact that
this the the way in which this
individual is is going to to to get a
brain device and that that's taking
place as part of a research protocol it
can often appear as though you're you're
going to let's say an academic Medical
Center and it might appears that that
research participant is is just
undergoing a standard clinical therapy
and particularly with implanted devices
where enrolling and research might
involve undergoing an invasive surgery
for instance individuals who consider
enrolling in research might not be fully
clear that they're enrolling in a
research protocol and not just just
undergoing a cutting-edge therapeutic
intervention and that there are also
concerns that participants might have
about just the invasiveness of brain
implants and you might think of
invasiveness as just concerns about
something going under the skin device
being implanted but if it's an if it's
not a brain implant there might also be
concerns about privacy and whether if
the device particularly is recording
neural data whether that's in base
of subjects privacy in a different way I
mean so that might deter potential
participants from enrolling in brain
device research studies I mean they're
just the medical and technological
complexity of brain devices I can pose
barriers to to a fully informed consent
process particularly if health literacy
might prevent a patient from fully
understanding the device itself and how
that device is expected to interplay
with a neurological disease process once
a subject has actually decided to enroll
in a clinical study their challenges
with ongoing consent and this can be
caused by just the impact of the brain
device itself on cognitive or affective
components of decision-making capacity
so even if a subject has decision-making
capacity when they enroll in a clinical
trial if the device itself may impact
decision-making over the course of a
study you might worry that there are
fluctuations in decision-making capacity
that can impact ongoing informed consent
with brain implants there are risks
involved in the surgical removal of a
brain device I mean making sure that
that a an ongoing that a person's
ongoing participation in a study
continues to be voluntary and informed
means that the participants need to
understand the risks of surgical removal
and those are separate from from the
initial risks of implantation those
risks that a subject might have been
thinking much more about when they
initially enrolled in a clinical trial
their risks of continued use and
implantation and sometimes these are
unknown or unforeseen risks that
longer-term stimulation may have even if
animal studies have given the research
team at a good sense of what the
short-term effects of stimulation are it
can be hard to predict what those
longer-term effects of stimulation we're
discussing devices neuromodulation
devices that use electrical stimulation
and then finally there are Britons of
really due to follow-up care with these
devices so it's burdens that
that made a career to a participant as
they're in a clinical trial but also as
they think about exiting from a clinical
trial there there might be concerns
about how to get access to that
follow-up care particularly if that's
that research subject doesn't want to
stay in a research study so that if the
clinical trial is the only way that a
subject can access that follow-up care
that might create some ethical concerns
about about coercion essentially or some
undue influence to stay in a research
study so I think these ethical
challenges create important obligations
and regulation FDA regulation that
applies to most brain device studies
focus on minimizing coercion and
protecting subject rights safety and
welfare so investigators need to be
attentive to issues related to ongoing
consent and preserving a subjects right
to decline surgical explant of devices
or their right to exit a study if if
their circumstances change and they no
longer wish to participate in research
it's important to plan for how to
protect that right to exit from a
research study and then there are
ongoing obligations that an investigator
has related to the control and
supervision of device use and so even if
a subject wishes to exit from a clinical
trial there are still obligations that a
researcher might have to report adverse
events and and so that's an ongoing
obligation they might have and I think
there's there's still a question about
exactly when these obligations and
responsibilities and because even in the
context of post trial access to devices
which we'll talk about soon some of
these obligations to report adverse
events or issues that arise related to
brain devices if subjects continue to
use them after a clinical trial in some
context it's clear that the
responsibilities investigators have
related to supervision of device use I
don't end exactly when the clinical
trial ends at the point that but
subjects are exiting from research and
there are important financial burdens to
consider and I found in some of my
qualitative research where I interviewed
subjects who either were exiting from a
clinical trial or had exited from a
clinical trial of a brain device within
the last five to ten years many of the
subjects told me that they they didn't
really think through many of the
financial burdens that might accrue to
them if they decided to continue to use
this investigational brain device after
the clinical trial ended so particularly
battery replacements that may be
required if a subject is experiencing
benefit and wishes to continue to
experience this benefit this battery
replacements can be costly and it
sometimes isn't fully clear to to
clinical trial participants whether the
sponsor or the researchers will continue
to pay for those device replacement
replacements or to pay for the follow-up
care that they'll need to continue to
receive and I think in as somebody
continues to be in a research study we
need to be attentive to whether those
financial burdens create a barrier to
withdrawal from research and my
influence potential participants to stay
in a research study even if there's
there's something that's changed in
terms of their motivations or their life
circumstances that might make them wish
to withdraw from research and finally
when we think about exit from research
there's a separate informed consent
process that needs to take place in
brain implant research related to the
surgical removal of a device so there
are additional risks related to you the
surgery itself to remove the device in
the context of deep brain stimulation
researchers found that the risks of
removing implanted electrodes are
actually higher usually the risk of a
bleed is actually higher upon removing
electrodes than even when they were
initially placed and so research
participants have described to me that
generally they were taking things one
step at a time
and they as they were initially
enrolling in research hadn't really
thought through there was additional
risks
I might agree to them at the point that
the device might be surgically removed
and so important trade offs come up at
the end of a research study there are
ongoing risks if subjects decide to keep
a device implanted but there are also
risks to having the device removed and
so there's that that risk benefit
analysis really needs to take place on
an individual basis if a research
subject for instance has had a change in
their health status over the course of
participation in a research study and
then there might need to be a really
individualized analysis for whether it's
ethically and medically appropriate to
remove that that brain device especially
if that subject might be experiencing
benefit from the device and if the risks
have changed since they initially
enrolled in research so when we think
about research oversight and while IRB
approval might depend on minimizing
risks to subjects and and that may in
some ways push form I'm avoiding
unnecessary risks either related to
excellent of a device or continued use
of a device if there are ongoing risks
of infection let's say with a brain
implant it's important to note that
there there might be a gap in research
oversight once once the end of the trial
has has taken place because IRB might
have limited post trial oversight once a
research study ends another concern that
that I've come across in terms of the
thought I put into exit from research
protocols is that there seems to be
significant variability from one
clinical trial to another in terms of
what procedures there are for exit from
a clinical study so there doesn't seem
to be a very standard or consistent
approach to just explaining what options
research participants have at the end of
a clinical trial or the consent process
that might take place I mean also being
the analysis of the risks and benefits
of surgical removal at these
investigational devices
these inconsistent practices raise
ethical concerns related to justice and
I think it's important that researchers
share the practices that they use are
the options that they provide related to
surgical removal or post trial use of
implanted devices in part to address
these justice concerns we don't want
different benefits to accrued just to
some research participants where others
might might feel the sense that they're
forced to have a device that's
benefitting them removed
just by virtue of variation and clinical
trial design in an unanswered question
at this point comes up related to post
trial access and requirements for post
trial access we we still have not
clarified whether there's truly an
obligation to allow participants to
continue to use brain implants if
they're benefiting from that
investigational implant once they're
exiting from a research study in post
trial axis has been discussed quite a
bit initially it was a topic that
received some ethical interest during
HIV clinical trials of therapies and the
treatment of HIV and when we think about
brain devices its FDA regulation that
would generally apply that would be the
regulatory constraints for offering post
trial access to brand devices and some
continued access to brain and devices is
not FDA required but it is permitted
under expanded access provisions I mean
this this usually requires some
preliminary evidence that the device is
safe and effective and it does create
these ongoing obligations that I
mentioned before for safety monitoring
and adverse event reporting and so if an
investigator decides that they are going
to make sure that that participants in
their clinical trial have access to the
investigational device after the trial
is ended that creates and while I'm
doing responsibilities for that
investigator to monitor whether there
are any adverse events even after the
Nicolle trial has ended so their
multiple stakeholders when you just guys
post trial access to brain devices and
not includes participants in these
clinical trials the clinical researchers
themselves who may accrue additional
obligations if they decide to offer post
trial access this study sponsor may have
an important stake in where their
approach trial axis is offered because
this may really change the costs of
sponsoring research the FDA and other
regulatory bodies clearly have some some
stake in this since it may change the
amount of regulatory oversight that
needs to be provided research oversight
bodies such as IRB may have limited
jurisdiction when it comes to post trial
access or post trial device use but they
may have a stake in in they may have a
role at least in examining whether
there's a good enough plan for what
happens to investigational brain
implants after after a clinical trial
ends healthcare insurers may have a
stake in that if a research study
doesn't pay for follow-up care at that
follow-up care for research participants
may accrue to health care insurers
instead and I would say the public also
has a stake in these questions about
post royal access there there might be
concerns that people who participate in
research may have preferential access to
brain devices but also the public might
have an interest in encouraging people
to participate in research to contribute
to generalizable knowledge about health
conditions
I assume the public may actually have an
interest in offering post trial access
to the extent that it may be fair but
also at may incentivize research
participation so two scenarios are
important to think about when we when we
consider the ethical issues in post
trial access the first would be somebody
who benefits from a brain implant in a
clinical trial that's overall
unsuccessful so it's likely that that
brain device because the the clinical
trial is not successful that brain
device might not go to market
and so the costs and burdens of device
maintenance may be difficult to justify
for a sponsor but but the the benefit
that an individual who experienced the
risks or under underwent the risks of
participating in this research trial is
an important countervailing
consideration and finally as a second
scenario would be a a non responder in
an otherwise a successful clinical trial
and so that that non-responder may if
the device were to continue to be turned
on there's a possibility that that the
FATA non-responder will eventually
become a responder but may just have a
delayed response and so this brings up
questions about clinical trial design
and clinical endpoints that are chosen
in designing these clinical trials but
also this non-responder may be concerned
about the risks of device removal if it
seems like removing the device is the
best balance of risks and benefits for
that participant and it's also important
to consider the psychological impact it
can be incredibly devastating for
research process participants who have
have exposed themselves to significant
risks and invested quite a bit of time
and and hope in their participation in a
clinical trial and it can be devastating
to feel like even the last resort even
even this experimental treatment that
they tried when no FDA approved
treatments could help them have failed
and when we think about some of the
trade-offs and offering post trial
access and there are people who argue
that post trial access should be
mandated in some sense because it's it's
really impossible in an informed consent
process to help a research participant
understand what it might be like to have
access to your therapy that benefits
them and then to lose that access merely
because a clinical trial has ended
there's some people who say that the
post trial access is consistent with
some of the the entrustment or the
duties of care
that investigators assumed as they
engage in relationships investigator
subject relationships with with study
participants and there are also concerns
about just that just whether reciprocity
or concerns to avoid X like exploitation
really really create an obligation to
provide post-trial access but on the
other hand richard saber describes that
opposition to continued access its
investigational technologies might be
based on concerns about impeding
research prof progress but it may if you
create indefinite obligation for
researchers to provide continued access
to these investigational therapies that
that might disincentivize research it
may in fact incentivize participants to
withdraw early from a research study
their concerns about preferential access
and and also whether whether in fact
providing post oral access to you
investigational therapies could
exacerbate therapeutic misconception
could really exacerbate
misunderstandings people have about the
nature of research as opposed to
clinical care the Declaration of
Helsinki provides a little bit of
guidance about post trial access it
encourages provision of post trial
access to any intervention that's
identified as beneficial in the trial
although it doesn't provide all that
much clarity about about what is
considered benefit whether a study has
to show efficacy on a cohort basis or
just in an individual assessment of
whether an individual research
participant is experiencing benefit the
neuroethics roadmap that was recently
published by the NIH brain initiative
provides some additional guidance on on
both post trial access and some of the
earlier ethical issues I described when
we think about recruitment and informed
consent as well as exit from research so
the brain initiative the neuroethics
roadmap published by the brain
initiative describes that we need
to be attentive to you informed consent
processes we need to outline in detail
the potential end of trial and post
trial responsibilities that
investigators have to research
participants I mean really get get over
IRB oversight of these these plans and
they are particularly attentive to the
idea that we need to pay attention to
whether participants benefit from study
participation and how that benefit will
be managed in plans for for the end of a
clinical trial
um additionally they described that it's
important when a non clinical scientist
is designing or conducting a human human
subjects trial that their clinicians
included on the research team who are
sensitive to some of the clinical
concerns in clinical considerations that
arise in in conducting clinical research
they also describe that that it's
important to consider to anticipate in
advance potential psychosocial risks to
research participants so that might
include change and concerns about
changes and self-identity their
personality changes but also would
include what I mentioned about some of
the psychological risks of attempting to
participate in clinical research hoping
to experience benefit when when a person
has tried many other therapies that have
not provided benefit and finally the
neuroethics roadmap encourages
researchers to use real-world samples to
to include participants who have
coexisting or comorbid conditions in
order to make sure that that research
results in in generalizable findings and
this is these are good ethical practices
as well as just good research practices
and the the neuroethics roadmap
specifically describes some post study
responsibilities researchers should be
attentive to such as developing detailed
protocols about how they will handle
post study follow-up and paying
attention to the often overlooked
physical and psychological risks that
even a successful
intervention may pose to research
participants I described briefly some of
my own neuroethics
research and I was specifically
exploring some of these questions about
what what research participants oh sorry
what researchers oh research
participants at the end of clinical
trials of implanted brain devices and I
think it can be incredibly helpful to
integrate neuroethics research into
ongoing clinical research one can simply
get advice from an ethicist as they're
designing clinical trials especially in
early phase research one could
collaborate with an ethicist to to
explore some unique ethical issues so
having an ethics of study or an ethics
aim to an ongoing clinical research
proposal can help you to explore the
ethical concerns that might not be
immediately evident when when
considering designing an early phase
clinical trial and one can also conduct
parallel empirical ethics studies to
make sure that that we are working
closely together to understand some of
the ethical implications of early phase
clinical research and I think I'll
describe just a couple of ways that some
of the empirical neuroethics research
that's been funded by the brain
initiative and other areas of NIH other
Institute's within at NIH which I think
this research can help us understand
multiple stakeholder perspectives in
ways that might not be completely
apparent and when when overseeing
research empirical neuroethics research
can also can also help us understand
some overlooked ethical concerns as well
as provide some insight into just the
impact of research safeguards that are
already in place and an important
unanswered question that I'll end with
is I think I focused on some ethical
issues that arise once we're actually
implanting brain devices into humans I
think it's important to also think about
how these findings
can inform researchers when there
earlier along this translational
research process I so how how can the
work that we've done in neuroethics
inform just decisions about whether to
translate from a preclinical study idea
first in human study I said to me this
is the next question about how to make
sure that that ethics research and
findings from the ethics research that's
being conducted can actually support
researchers early along in the process
when these findings can be most
impactful down the road in translational
research that's what I will stop there I
hope to receive some questions from from
anyone who has questions after after
seeing this presentation and thank you
for your attention